THE SECRETARY PROMISED THAT
MONTHS AGO.
THE REASON THERE IS NO
CONCLUSION TO THE INVESTIGATION
IS BECAUSE THE INVESTIGATORS ARE
IN A TOUGH SPOT.
THSECRETARY, THE PRESIDENT AND
VICE PRESIDENT, IN A REAL
INVESTIGATION, THEY DID, THE
POLICY IS CLEAR.
I STARTED MY CAREER IN BORDER
PATROL.
I'VE SEEN THE VIDEO.
THESE OFCERS DID NOTHING
WRONG, THEY DID THEIR JOB.
THEY USED THEIR HORSES THE SAME
WAY THEY USE HORSES IN TIMES
SQUARE FOR CROWD CONTROL.
THEY DID THEIR JOB.
THE ONLY ONE, THE HAITIAN
MIGRANTS, A CRIME, A
MISDEMEANOR, THEY IGNORED VERBAL
COMMANDSROM DERAL OFFICERS WHIC
THE INVESTIGATION TO END.
THEY USE STATEMENTS TO THE
PRESIDENT SAYING IS UPON AND
THESE AGENTS WERE PAID,
STATEMENTS FROM THE VICE
PRESIDENT SAYING IT IS A RACIST
ISSUE.
THE SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY SAID HE WAS APPALLED
AND THEY ATTACK CHILDREN.
THE SAME SECRETARY SAYS FAIR,
INDEPENDENT REVIEWER
INVESTIGATION, AND BY VILIFYING
MEN AND WOMEN ON HORSEBACK.
WITH THESE ADVOCACY GROUPS THE
WHITE HOUSE SUPPORTS, AND STATUS
FOR HAITIAN MIGRANTS.
AND IF THEY ARE DEPORTED BUT
SUING THE GOVERNMENT YOU CAN'T
REMOVE THEM AND LITIGATION.
THESE LAWSUITS MAKE THE
GOVERNMENT BRING THEM INTO THE
UNITED STATES TO DO LITIGATION.
A LOT OF CONTENTIOUS LAWSUITS,
THAT IS WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
LINING THEIR POCKETS TO GET SOME
SORT OF REWARD FOR THOSE WHO
BROKE THE LAW INTO THE COUNTRY.
TODD: I UNDERSTAND FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF OPEN-DOOR
ADVOCACY GROUPS, THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT, WE DON'T AGREE WITH THAT
THEY ARE FIGHTING FOR THEIR
ASIDE.
I UNDERSTAND THE FIGHT HTIAN
MIGRANTS WANTS TO COME TO THE
US, DON'T AGREE WITH THE WAY
THEY ARE DOING IT BUT UNDERSTAND
IT.
WHAT I CAN'T WRAP MY HEAD AROUND
IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
NUMBER ONE JOB IS TO ENFORCE THE
NATION'S BORDERS AND
RULE OF LAW.
IN BOTH INSTANCES THEY ARE NOT
DOING IT BY HELPING THE PEOPLE
BRINGING SUIT AGAINST THE
GOVERNMENT, TH APPLICATION IS
CORRECT, WHAT SAY YOU?
>> AGREE WITH WHAT YOU JUST
SAID.
THESE LAWSUITS SEND A BAD
MESSAGE BECAUSE THEY HOPE THE
GOVERNMENT SETTLE THESE CASES ON
THE COURSE BECAUSE OF NUISANCE
FACTORS.
WHEN I WAS ICE DIRECTOR, I
REFUSED TO SETTLE OUT OF COURT.
I SAID WE DID NOTHING WRONG.
OUR ATTORNEYS WOULD LITIGATE AND
VOCACY GROUP THAT WANTS TO DO
NOTHING BUT LINE THEIR POCKETS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION REFUSED TO
ENFORCE IMMIGRATION LAWS OTHE
BORDER AND THIS IS THE RESULT OF
NOT ENFORCING LAWS, REWARDIN
GOALS WHO BREAK OUR LAWS
THAN HAVE SOME SORT OF TURN TO
BREAK THE LAW.
>> I